a lot of Clark County Schools have
wrapped up Nevada reading week to
highlight the importance of reading but
for students over at Bozarth Elementary
School their excitement about reading it
is year round as Victoria Saha found out
it's thanks to a new machine that gives
them a book of their choice
this is
reading is a big deal for the students
and Miss Amanda gubler's library then
you start to know more words and you
recognize them with all the technology
that we have in front of us the joy and
the magic that holding a physical book
in your hands and owning it is important
not like me brown bear brown bear was my
very first book that I remember getting
to keep but these days the students at
Bozarth Elementary are getting their
first book through a reward system and
it all starts with good behavior
no it's not a snack waiting at the
bottom of the vending machine
a book I was so excited I think there
was three or four slots empty and it was
full this morning you get to keep the
books and you get to read them when you
want to this vending machine doesn't
take cash or card it only accepts a gold
coin you can get a gold coin only if you
saved up 20 champ tickets so how do you
get your hands on one of those being
quiet in class and
um participating in special second
grader Brody Colin has been on his best
behavior as he saved up his champ
tickets and he finally had enough to get
a gold coin it's a moment he's been
waiting for
a new tool changing the lives of
students one book at a time Victoria
Saha eight news now